hello everyone and welcome to round nine
of the 2021 uh tata steel chess
tournament in a game between magnus
carlsen and niels grandelius niels who
was leading the tournament
for the for the first part of the
tournament but uh then he lost a few
games
but he has a very colorful tournament he
already has three wins and two draw
two losses to anish giri and hari
krishna but
um now he faces world champion magnus
carlsen and magnus suffered his first
defeat in the previous round uh we
checked out that game it was
it was quite a beauty if you haven't
seen it i will put it in the description
below so check it out as it's
just just awesome uh and now it's
interesting to see what magnus will
choose with the white pieces to try and
get back into this tournament
as he now most definitely needs a win he
won only the first game
uh he played against alireza in the
tournament and then uh had a series of
draws before losing
uh in the previous round so uh without
further ado let's check out what happens
here as this game
uh we have a lot to cover so magnus with
the white pieces
opens with e4 and nils opts for c5
so again uh we'll see if we will again
have the neighborhood on the board and
can
the night of even survive one game in
this tournament
so knight and that's now the knight
knight to f3 d6 and
d4 striking the center captures captures
knight to f6
knight to c3 and a6 again uh the knight
of sicilian is on the board
and uh let's see what magnus chooses
here so
whenever we uh show a game that was
played in the night or if i often
mentioned that bishop e3 bishop g5
bishop e2 bishop c4
are the absolute top top top four moves
that
you play in this position but there are
plenty of other moves you can play h3h4
you can play
f3 you can play even g4 you can play
a3 you can play a4 so a lot of moves are
possible here but magnus goes for an
extremely rare queen to d3
and this is uh so rare that uh niels
really started thinking in this position
because this is something you
don't encounter quite often and uh i
remember when i was thinking about the
what uh what you could use against the
night of
if you if you were playing against
someone who plays the night of uh queen
to d3 does not come up
all that often so here uh magnus wants
to surprise nils with this and
let's see what's the idea behind queen
to d3 because
for the moment it it looks like it's
just blocking that bishop on f1 so let's
see what was
carlson's idea uh niels continues with
e6
which is a standard move in this setup
uh very nicely done
we have a for by magnus stopping black's
expansion here on the queen side
knight to c6 and here magnus trades with
knight characters b
captures black now gets a massive pawn
chain here in the center
and now queen to g3 and this is the idea
behind queen to d3
shift to the queen over to g3 where you
still have pressure on the d6 pawn but
also you are preventing black from cap
from developing the dark square bishop
uh and here there is one game in the
database uh a top level game between
grigori operin and the boris gate fund
where d5 was played
the game ended in a draw it was a blitz
game in 2017 played in siri
but here we have bishop to b7 and it is
as of move 9 that we have a completely
new game
so let's see how carlson deals with
bishop to b7
uh also a very interesting here is h5
i'm just going to show it because it's
it is interesting threatens h4 and it
does appear to be
the top idea against this queen to g3
line of course white will play
h4 and now bishop to e7 and black
continues
development and castles next because the
g7 pawn
is not something you want to grab if you
grab this rook to g8 queen h6 and now d5
and it's black who who will have uh
you know a very pleasant game he has the
semi-open g file for the rook he has
this massive center
and it's very easy for him to bring the
pieces into the game
i'm just going to show one funny line e5
rook the beach
uh b6 kicks away the queen queen f4 and
now rook to g4
again chases away the queen and after
the queen moves
now you shift the knight from f6 as it's
under attack
captures captures with check and now
king d1 and this is
a complete madness on the board so who
knows what what's happening here
so okay that's that's kind of the idea
behind h5
but nils went for bishop to b7 and now
magnus continues developing bishop to e2
and you'll see how how nicely the this
bishop is placed on e2 with bishop to e7
now offering the g7 pawn but not now of
course you don't capture it if queen
captures again rook to g8 and
we get a fairly similar position with
the this bishop already developed on b7
so magnus ignores that and plays bishop
to f4 now saying
i'm preparing to push e5 and if you want
to stop that you have to play e5
yourself
point is if uh niels just castles and
allows this e5 move it's a it's a very
dangerous idea because white will
have this pressure here constantly on
the g7 pawn
and not a lot black can do about that so
instead after bishop to f4 niels blocks
it with e5
magnus goes back bishop to e3 and now
niels castles and here situation on the
clock is
magnus says an hour and 20 minutes on
the clock so he'll he
wasted very little time here whereas
niels is below one hour clock
uh a point as he's on some 58 minutes
uh and here we have castles by magnus he
also decides to castle king side and now
uh king the h8 now king to h8 you wanna
uh well you wanna free the the king away
from this diagonal
uh as at some point you wanna move this
knight you wanna push the f5 pawn so
king to h8
definitely makes sense and you don't
want to have your king and g8
are constantly worrying about moves like
bishop to h6 that will
uh of course uh attack your pin pawn so
king to h8
and for this king to h8 move uh neil
spent some 20 minutes so that's uh you
know he's burning time like crazy here
uh we have a5 by magnus grabbing more
space on the queen side now
ideas like bishop to b6 become possible
knight can come to a4 and then to b6
so again a little bit more for nils to
worry about but niels sticks to his plan
he goes knight to d7 prepares this f5
thrust
and here uh magnus brings more firepower
to the d
file uh rook f2d1 and now
uh we have f5 by nils and this is a this
is a wonderful idea
uh because magnus captured it and niels
just played d5 so he a temporary pawn
sacrifice to uh
increase his activity in the center uh
because if you go
after this pawn then white has all sorts
of tricky ideas like queen to h3
now attacks this puts pressure on h7 if
you move the rogue bishop to
the c4 attacks the rook here and now
it's uh it's a crazy position where if
black it
decides to go d5 you can even give up a
piece here captures captures bishop
captures
bishop captures the rook captures and
now there's a double attack on the
knight
and there's no way to defend this if
bishop to f8 you defend it like this
just rook a to d1 and that's just it no
no more options here uh the knight is
attacked three times and even uh
this is covered by the bishop so you
cannot defend against this
so you'd have to move the queen but then
just captures and
white is white is having an
an amazing position if queen captures on
c2 going after the rook here
you just kick the queen away queen back
rook back to d2 kicks the queen away
and you enjoy a better position so
instead after e captures on f5 we have
this d5 move by niels also with ideas of
pushing d4
and here magnus also went into a thing
and
he played knights to a4 which is uh
which has been an idea from the start
you want to get it the knight over to b6
but i'm just gonna show just for fun
because i know you guys enjoy it so much
a funny line that starts with queen to
h3 uh here again you're
uh you're again having a lot of pressure
uh
on the knight on the h7 pawn and also
you are inviting black to play d4 but if
black goes for this d4 idea
you're gonna play bishop to c1 and now
uh the knight is off limits black needs
to figure out
what black will play uh because if you
capture the knight
then just f6 and white wins so as simple
as that because now there's a double
attack here
uh the bishop is under attack and even
with the with the best reply let's say
captures bishop captures and now
uh bishop the c8 you just moved the
bishop to add another defender to the
knight
captures captures and now let's say
queen to g3
and it's an amazing position for white
this bishop is a monster the
the rooks are very nicely placed the
other rook can come into the game very
easily
and it's a a beautiful position for
white like i said
uh but okay uh instead of that after d5
magnus went for knight to a4 he wants to
place this knight over on b6
uh and now comes uh well uh
d4 and what happens now so the bishop is
under attack magnus has to move it we
have d2 and now
even c5 so opening up the light square
diagonal
and uh preparing to to to bring the rest
of the pieces into the game
uh the f5 pawn still under attack magnus
plays queen to h3
defends the pawn and again put some
pressure here maybe he can bring some of
the attackers into the game
but now comes uh bishop to g5 uh
challenging this uh bishop here and uh
well if
magnus trades then um anil just gets his
queen into the game
so here after considering the position
for for a while
magnus decides to trade here we have
queen captures
and now rook to e1 uh and here a
situation on the clock is 28 minutes
magnus and 23 minute nils
uh and uh well it's just uh
just a very very tough position to to
play the g2 pawn is under attack by the
bishop and the queen the rook can come
into the game rook and
capture an f5 you can then double up
rooks here and magnus really needs to
decide how to play this so here
magnus goes bishop uh sorry first niels
goes bishop to e4
it just goes after this pawn says that
this wasn't maybe the the best idea
and now magnus counters that with bishop
to d3 so
niels picks up the pawn we have bishop
captures and
rook captures on f5 now uh clearing the
dfa square for the other rook
uh and now uh knight to b6 asking do you
wanna
play play something weird like a rook to
d8 or do you want to trade on b6
and then i will get a nice pass pawn so
here niels decides uh to take on b6 we
have knight captures on b6
a captures on b6 and now h6 just
creating some breeding room for the king
saying that this is not a problem uh
it's at any point i can just bring more
attackers here eliminate this past pawn
it's not going to survive very long
so here magnus plays queen to d3 now
with a double attack on the a6 pawn and
neil says
no problem i'm just going to play rook
to b8 if you're thinking about
this sort of a counter attack with rook
to f8 it does seem like it's very nice
but after rook to f1
uh there is not all that much for black
to do you can go queen f6 the triple on
the f file but just b7 now is very
strong
and now you cannot capture on f2 because
of b8 queen
and now whatever you play white will
definitely come out on top captures
captures
and there's nothing much for you to do
queen captures here you're gonna capture
here
and one of the queens remains on the
board it's of course completely
uh winning for white so after this b7
move uh you're
you'd have to play something else you
you'd have to play something like c4
but then after queen captures on c4 now
you can capture an f2 but it's a
it's it's a really tricky line that uh
in the end just for example captures on
f2 you can bring the queen into the game
uh now uh requires you to go for this uh
rook capture sun g2 check king captures
on g2 and now queen to g6 check and it's
a very very
uh very crazy line uh if king goes here
queen to e4 with
check and then it's just just a force to
draw so it is possible to
go for something like this after rook a
to f8 but niels decides to go for rook
to b6
just uh blocking that pawn magnus grabs
on a6
and now comes rook to f6 saying okay i'm
now gonna pick up the
b-pawn and there's not much you can do
about it point is if magnus
goes for something like queen to b5 to
defend this pawn uh then queen d2 is
very annoying uh this is threat in this
threat and this is threatened
and you now have to go back and then
after a queen trade you just pick off
the
the pawn and it's a a completely equal
position
so instead after rook to f6 magnus goes
g3 he prepares a very sneaky line
after the pawn is captured uh we have
rook f captures on b6
rook captures rook captures and now f4
and this is uh
what magnus had in mind when he played
this g3 move
uh but uh the problem for niels is that
niels is very low on time here
but you're you know comfortable at your
own home so feel free to pause the video
and try to find the only good move for
nils here while i give you a couple of
seconds
so uh uh for those of you who were able
to do it congratulations on spotting the
move we already
saw the move once in this game uh for
for similar reasons
uh so prepare yourselves uh and for
those of you who just want to enjoy the
show it's c4 this is the only good move
for white here
point being that after the queen
captures on c4 you can now capture an f4
and now the point is the queen is no
longer here guarding the h7 square
and now after this check is delivered
it's not checkmate you can move the king
and now even after queen to g8 to check
king to g6 uh there is no good reply
here for example rookie 6 check
captures captures with check and black
can just play
queen f6 amazingly this is a draw
captures captures
a g captures an f4 king here and now b4
but after king captures you can see that
king is well within the square of the
pawn
uh it's not a problem for the black king
to reach this past pawn and then
black will start pushing his pawns in
the end it's going to be a draw
but uh this was in the position for
niels after this f4 move so extremely
hard to find
especially with such a little so little
time on the clock so niels went back
with the queen
but this means that magnus will now win
a pawn so here
rook captures on e5 rook captures on b2
and now
rook captures on c5 now magnus is up a
pawn
and he will of course try ideas like
queen f5
go after this uh position from the
thumbnail maybe win the queen maybe in
the game quickly
so here queen to a8 uh with some ideas
of rook b1
check maybe you can do something with
this setup but magnus goes for the
absolute best king to f2 not allowing
anything to come with
check and you don't really have uh all
that many great options here
and here uh the carlson has some eight
minutes on the clock and niels has some
55 seconds
so here we have rook back to b8 not
allowing
any any tricks along the back rank and
now queen to f3 now magnus offers a
queen trade
and you cannot go into this uh uh rook
and pawn uh and king end game because
the black king is just too far away
so here queen to a7 and now queen to d5
by magnus
saying that okay now i might even win uh
another pawn and it's gonna be very hard
for you to play this
now there was this sneaky d3 in the
position
uh it kind of makes things tough for
white because after c
captures you opened up this diagonal you
can now go queen b6
uh threaten ideas like this but white is
still up to pawn so black will have a
very very difficult time uh defending
this but it was possible
however after queen d5 we have queen to
a1 by niels
and now magnus finds queen to e5 puts
pressure on the rook here
and prepares uh some very nasty stuff
with
the rook along the sixth and seventh
rank so here queen to b2 defending the
rook now rook c6
threatening to capture the pawn here
because the g pawn is pinned so king h7
niels of course defends against this
now rook the c7 threatening checkmate so
rook to g8
and now finally magnus decides to bring
the king somewhat
somewhat closer to safety with king to
g2
uh if you if magnus didn't want to
play too safe for example f5 f6 is in
the position but he wants to
get his king to safety he had too many
draws and even lost the game in the
previous
round to mess this one up so he wants to
play this one
by the book so here uh we have queen to
b4
uh and now comes queen to e4 check king
to h8 and the rook to d7 this is what
magnus goes for
he says everything is nicely defended uh
sorry
i'm now going to win this pawn and then
i'm just going to be up two points and
you don't really have an active move
here
but he will have to calculate some of
the checks after queen to d2
and this is exactly what niels goes for
queen today to check king h3 and queen
to d1 now
preparing to maybe uh do some sneaky
attacks from uh from
from behind uh but here magnus just
plays uh
rook to e7 now it's very interesting
magnus goes to rook to a7 with the idea
of trading rooks but
uh it's always dangerous to go for for a
queen uh queen end game because those
are the absolute hardest games to play
uh queen ends games being up upon it's
like uh you have to play it to
perfection to actually uh
make use of that extra pawn here magnus
had the the very promising king to h4
but it requires too much calculation in
in in an already sort of a winning
position
uh but i will show it because it's very
interesting king h4 and now
you're pretty much out of check so you
don't have to worry about queen to h5
anymore
but you have to worry about the g5 check
and now the point is after captures and
captures you go back
king to h3 your only move and now after
queen f1 check
king to g4 now you're gonna get queen to
d1 check but now queen f3
and now you have to yeah you have to
trade queens otherwise queen f6
check and it's game over so here you
have to trade and now you have uh you
have a winning end game for white
even though you're just up one pawn i'm
just going to show how easily winning it
is for example rook c8
black wants to collect some pawns white
says okay you're welcome to collect
those pawns and if you collect those
pawns
captures rook captures king g6 it's game
over black is getting checkmated and
that's it
nothing uh for black to do here so king
h4 very sneaky move it was in the
position
uh magnus decides to go uh the longer
route he wants to trade rooks and then
play the the the most hated end game uh
there ever was
the queen and queen and pawn in the game
so here uh we have queen to h5
check king to g2 and sorry king to g2
and now
rook back to c8 putting pressure uh
along this
c file so white has to be somewhat
careful with the queen but now
magnus b as he cannot trade anymore this
is covered by the queen and by rook he
goes
f6 the idea of f5 the idea of course is
f6 pawn captures and queen to h7
checkmate
and niels needs to find something to
defend against this so he finds queen to
d1
now threatening to pick up this pawn but
now magnus goes for
rook to e8 to check i'm just going to
show what niels had in mind if magnus
continued with his f6 idea then magnus
would lose the game
because after rook captures on c2 with
check king h3
uh you have queen to h5 check and now
the king cannot go back you have to
block with the queen
queen f5 check queen to g4 and now queen
to f1
check pushing the king of the board king
to h4 and now
rook captures on h2 with check queen h3
and now this is just checkmate
so uh the position is not without poison
and nils finds it with queen to d1
so magnus decides to trace rooks here uh
captures captures
uh in the now after uh king to h7 magnus
goes queen to e4 now threatening
f6 to come with check so niels goes back
aking to h8 and now
magnus could play this position in a in
a few different ways he could start with
with pushing of the pawn he could start
by improving the safety of the king he
decides to go for queen to e8 to check
uh king to h7 queen to g6 with check
king to h8 of course not here because
then f6 is just winning
you will not be able to capture and now
f6 but
f6 uh to calculate f6 you first have to
see what happens after all the checks
come because the pawn will be captured
but it's not a problem
queen e2 check king to h3 and now queen
to e6 with
check you could also go for queen to f1
check but you can never capture this
pawn with the queen
because the king and pawn end game is
winning for magnus so here uh
queen to e6 would check king to h4
finally the king finds his way all the
way to h4 you can see that
indeed the king is very safe there g
captures and now
queen captures with check king g8 and
now queen to g6
with check uh king to f8 and now
g4 now magnus slowly needs to improve
the position of his uh king and push the
king up the board and push those pawns
up the board
so queen to e5 and now comes h3
as the pawn was under attack so king to
e7 and now queen to f5
again uh niels cannot afford a queen
trade queen to e3 was played
and now a very interesting position
where for the last time pause the video
and win this game for magnus
while i give you a couple of seconds
so uh for those of you who are able to
do it congratulations on being a true
master of the end game and for those of
you who just want to enjoy the show
it's king to h5 this is what you have to
do to win games sometimes you have to
give your precious pawn up
to improve the position of the king and
then go after the pawn this is what
magnus played
we have queen captures on h3 with check
king to g6 and now there is no way to
defend the pawn here
uh you could try queen to h4 but then
just king to g7
and uh blacks black's position is just
terrible there's nothing for
for the y for the black queen to do
there so instead we have king to d6
and now comes king captures on the on f6
the problem with queen captures with
check is that you're giving too much
activity to the black king and after
king to c5 you're gonna have to
you're gonna have to work a bit harder
for your meal so here instead
king captures was played saying that i'm
not interested in this if this check
comes king f7 and there are no more
checks everything is covered
so here niels after king f6 uh tried
queen to e3
but now magnus just goes to g5 and now
this pawn is marching all the way up the
board
queen to e7 check luckily this square is
available for
carlson's king so king g6 queen to e8
with check and now
came to g7 we have queen to e7 with
check now king to g8
and it was in this position that niels
grandelius resigned the game and
magnus carlsen gets his second win of
the tournament
uh because after one more check is
delivered you can block with the queen
and this block now comes with
check and that's uh that's pretty much
it captures captures and the past pawn
is winning
uh so really really insane game uh
could have i'm not going to say could
have gone either way because nils never
had an
actual shot in this game but he did have
chances to
uh pl play better moves um
but it's that's one of the reasons i
guess why this queen to d3 knight of
line
uh is not played at the absolute top
level but
magnus here makes it work so you know uh
whenever you play against the night or
you could always give this queen d3
queen g3 maneuver a shot i know i will
and we'll we'll see what happens so you
know uh
a very interesting line i i've checked
in the opening
database it's like the 15th most popular
line this queen to d3 but you know uh
modern engines are changing the way
chess is played
so we're gonna i'm pretty sure we're
gonna see a resurfacing of
of all of these uh never never played
old lines uh
now in maybe 2021 and especially
even after uh but yeah after this move
uh niels resigned and a great victory
for magnus so we're gonna show some
other games from round nine and then
we're gonna discuss the standings a bit
uh but that's it for this game so uh
hope you guys enjoyed it uh i would like
to thank kevin amel cargill and uh alex
francis julia truchas
samuel schmidt and samuel nathan bennett
for a contribution to my channel
thank you a lot i really appreciate it
uh as usual you can check to all my
previous videos here
thank you for watching and i will see
you soon continuing the coverage of the
tata steel
uh checking up on your wonderful
suggestions and whatever else happens in
the chess world
so thank you all i will see you soon and
have an excellent rest of your day